يركز العالم على حرب روسيا
واوكرانيا وفي الوقت الذي تصاعد
فيه التوتر الامريكان والسعوديين
جاءت الفرصة لواشنطن للعودة
البيت الابيض لا يزال لدينا قلق
كبير تجاه التجربة النووية
تجاهه كما ستدين القمة التعسفات
الاسرائيلية ضد الفلسطينيين
المحتملة لكوريا الشمالية. نائبة
تنتقد تجاهل الغرب لمعاناة
واليمن وليبيا وسوريا على رأس
الاهتمامات. الاحداث والتطورات.
الحدث بارسال رسالة الى القمة
حيث اكد على اهمية الدور الذي
حضور ملك المغرب بقولها انه
اعتذر هنا ضاعت الفرصة الذهبية
البلدين الشقيقين. ما استبق
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
جين بينغ. فيالى ماكري كوم يا
ابناء العم سام. الجزائر العرب.
يا سادة بلقاء ملك المغرب ورئيس
الجزائر بعد ارتفاع التوترات بين
لكن لم يسفر الاتصال عن اي
توافقات حيث نددت الصين بما
وذلك حسب طلب امريكا فكيف سترد
بكين! لكن البيت الابيض يصرح!
وشرعت بنشر قاذفاتها النووية
بشمال استراليا. واشنطن تفاوض
المتجمد بين وزير الخارجية
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن الصيني
في مقابلة مع صحيفة بيلد يقول
انه يخشى ان تهبط الصين ذات يوم
تقول التقارير ان الرياض زودت
واشنطن بمعلومات استخباراتية بان
للسعودية لاختيار حلفيها. لتبدأ
الهواتف بالرنين ويكسر الجليد
مع ان خال من الهواء. بكين تمضي
على الارض كما تفعل في الفضاء.
على القمر وتعلن ان القمر للارض
من املاكها الخاصة. فيا لا
بتقدم الصين وروسيا بتكنولوجيا
صواريخ الفرض صوتية. وامريكا في
والبلدان في حالة تأهب قصوى بحسب
وسائل الاعلام الامريكية. ليخرج
معلومات مع واشنطن تحذر من هجوم
ايراني وشيك على اهداف بالمملكة.
جاءت فرصة غير متوقعة للامريكان
ليظهروا تحالفهم مرة اخرى مع
لاحتلال القمر. ماذا? نعم يا
سادة هنا رئيس ناسا بيل نيلسون
النتائج بايديهم. هذا ما استجد
في الساحة الاعلامية لكل الاطراف
بحاجة اوروبا الى الاستثمار في
الدفاع الصاروخي لمواجهة ما وصفه
باعداد نظام لدخول الاجانب الى
روسيا بدون تأشيرات. فما الذي
تستعدان لعمل مناورات عسكرية
مشتركة بالقرب من الحدود الصينية
الغذاء الى الحرب الاوكرانية?
حيث اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانية
الاستعدادات جارية على قدم وساق.
وبينما تستكمل الجزائر اجراءاتها
خسائر فادحة خاصة في الطائرات
الايرانية المسيرة. واضاف ان
بيد ويدها الاخرى لا تتوقف عن
التحرش. هنا امريكا والهند
تلعبه دول الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا قائلا ان دول الشرق
العمل جار لعقد لقاء قمة بين
الرئيس بايدن ونظيره الصيني شي
حقوق الانسان. وزير الاعلام
اليمني. ثلاثة ملايين يمني
سيتعرضون للغازات السامة اذا حدث
تسرب بخزان صافر النفطي. بينما
المشتركة مع روسيا وبلا روسيا.
وهو رد غير متوقع وزير الدفاع
الفلسطينيين واليمنيين ومسلمي
الايجور وتقول توقفوا عن تسيس
وصفته بسياسة الاحتواء والقمع
الامريكية ضدها غير انها ابدت
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا التي يبلغ
عدد سكانها ما يقرب من نصف مليار
القمة فقد تخرج هامة بخصوص سد
النهضة وادانة افعال اثيوبيا
لاستضافة القمة العربية حسمت
حكومة الجزائر رسميا امكانية
استعدادها للحوار مع واشنطن
ليأتي هذا بعد ان خططت امريكا
يخطط له بوتين? اما البيت الابيض
فقد اعلنها? لا نسعى للحرب مع
نسمة تلعب دورا متزايد الاهمية
في هذه العملية. ينتظر العرب هذه
بلاده تسعى لاتاحة طرق برية عبر
بولندا او رومانيا فهل تفلح هذه
العالم. لتعلن فرنسا انها تدرس
امكانية توفير طرق بديلة لتصدير
اوكرانيا ستجعل الجيش الروسي في
مراتب تصنيف متدنية. لتخرج هنا
الحبوب والمواد الغذائية من
واوضح وزير الزراعة الفرنسي ان
هذه الشجاعة ايها اللاتفيون ومن
الذي معكم? ليرد بوتين ويوعز
الثلاثة الخارجية الامريكية ترد
بانها تترك الفرصة للصين والخيار
وبعد اعلان زيارة رئيس الصين
شيشن بينج الى السعودية والقمم
واقتصاديا وعسكريا قد اصحاب
العيون الضيقة بل انهم يسعون
تعد شوكة في حلق الولايات
المتحدة بل صارت المنافسة الاول
والمصادر سنضعها لكم في اول
تعليق. البعبع الصيني. الصين لم
دهائكم ايها الصينيون. وماذا عن
العلم الامريكي الذي يرفرف هناك
الانذار في عديد الاوكرانية فيما
قال زلينسكي ان روسيا تتكبد
حالة التأهب الجوي في عدة مناطق
بالبلاد هذا الاعلان سبقه صافرات
مصرحا نواصل وساطتنا بين
السعودية وايران والاجتماعات لكن
للامريكان والمكانة التي تحتلها
امريكا كاقوى دولة سياسيا
ايران قد تنفذ هجوما ضد السعودية
واربيل ليخرج الرئيس العراقي
يجري هل ستدافع واشنطن عن
السعودية كما فعلت في اوكرانيا?
انابيب الغاز السيل الشمالي
فحواها اتس دان اي انتهى الامر.
بعدم استخدام ممر تصدير الحبوب
لاغراض عسكرية عقاب وابتزاز
برسالة وزير الخارجية الامريكي
انتوني بلينكن فور تفجير خط
نتردد في عن مصالحنا ومصالح
حلفائنا في الشرق. لكن ما الذي
وتقول المتحدثة الرسمية باسم
وزارة الخارجية الروسية ماريا
اللاتفي الذي قال لسنا وحدنا في
حال هجمتم علينا. من اين لكم بكل
لها من احوال وبينما تصاعدت
التوترات بين السعودية وامريكا
تهديدات ايران للسعودية. ونحن
على اتصال مستمر مع المملكة. لن
المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي. ويقول نشعر بالقلق من
المملكة. هنا تقارير عن مسؤولين
سعوديين وامريكيين. الرياض
استئناف تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانية
الى اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا. فيما
الحبوب ومواد زراعية اخرى
الموانئ الاوكرانية. نعم. لقد تم
قال اردوجان ان بلاده نقلت اكثر
من تسعة ملايين طن من القمح الى
المرة بريطانيا. وبرغم انه لم
يمض على سلطاتها غير خمسة
هي روسيا تحصل على معلومات
استخباراتية تفيد ان ترس قد بعثت
ها هي المشاهد تتبدل ليعيش
المخرج دور الممثل. وبرغم تعليق
كفة. ما بين غمضة عين وانتباهتها
يغير الله من حال الى حال ويا
الناتو بالتهديدات الروسية
المستقبلية. فقد اعترف الحلف
ومن حرب الاستخبارات الى حرب
الغذاء والمجاعة هنا يكشف بوتين
انه لم ينسحب من اتفاق الغذاء
ولكنه **** مشاركة بلاده في
والغرب. جهاتها اعتبرت الولايات
المتحدة وان مطالبة موسكو كييف
الاتفاق فقط. الرئيس الروسي يريد
التزامات من كييف بعدم استخدام
واربعين يوما فان رئيسة الوزراء
البريطانية ليزر تراس قد تورط
بلادها مرة اخرى. وبعد ان تحدث
الاعلام عن اختراق هاتف ترس ها
لاتفيا وتعلن تحدي روسيا وتعلن
ايضا حالة طوارئ في الحدود
روسيا ان تحصل اوكرانيا على
الدعم الذي يجعلها تتفاوض من
موقع قوة. فعن اي قوة يتحدثون
القوة كشف عنها حلف الناتو وذلك
هل حقا فعلت رئيسة الوزراء
البريطانية ذلك فبما سترد ترامس
الخطة? ام ان بوتين سيقصفها
بتهمة تهريب الاسلحة? ومن حرب
روسيا اتفاق الحبوب غادرت عشر
سفن شحن على الاقل محملة باطنان
جماعي. انسيتم مقولتكم الشهيرتي.
هؤلاء النفط مقابل الغذاء واليوم
اوكرانيا. وترى اجهزة المخابرات
البريطانية ان خط الدفاع قادر
ممر الحبوب لاغراض عسكرية. وها
نحن بانتظار الرد من اوكرانيا
الجديد فبوتين يحافظ بكل قوة على
قطعة الجاتو التي اقتطعها من
على ردع اي هجوم اوكراني مضاد
وسريع وهو ما يؤكد اهمية المنطقة
الدفاع هذا بانه سلاح بوتين
الجديد ستتحطم عليه دبابات
هنا وبحسب الفرنسية مجموعة فاجنر
بدأت ببناء خط دفاع يتكون من كتل
خرسانية وخنادق شرق اوكرانيا
بينما وصف الاعلام الروسي خط
لدى الروس. فما الذي سيفعله
الاوكران لمواجهة سلاح بوتين
هاتف تريس وانما يهمها معرفة
اجابة لندن على السؤال التالي.
زاخاروفا انه لا يهمها من وكيف
حصل على المعلومات السرية من
تاريخية هامة وسط غياب ملك
المغرب بوتين يرسل رسالة للدول
الاراضي الاوكراني. وهنا سلاح من
نوع اخر يطلقه الروس والهدف هذه
يغني على ليلاه. لكن روسيا تلعب
باحترافية في المقامات السياسية.
كارثة جديدة. روسيا تضع يدها
بطون الغرب. كل يعد العدة وكل
العربية وكوريا الشمالية تقلق
الامريكان كالعادة. واليمن يواجه
تعلن تحدي الدب الروسي فيما
امريكا تتقرب من بموعد غرامي.
والجزائر تستكمل استعدادها
للقمة. والعرب امام قرارات
الولايات المتحدة ترد على زيارة
الرئيس الصيني للسعودية.
الذي يجري؟ روسيا تملي شروطها
لانقاذ العالم من الجوع.
وبوتين يشهر سلاحه الجديد خط
الدفاع وبريطانيا في ورطة. فما
واردوغان يتدخل وفرنسا تدرس خطة
بديلة للخروج من الورطة. لاتفيا
وبدون سابق انذار. واشنطن تعود
للدفاع عن الرياض. فما القصة؟
لحليفهم الخليجي الغني. فهل
ينتهزون هذه